the world of sound opened a whole Vista
in the world of motion picture making
and new developments in this field are
made every day or as mr. Jolson so
wisely predicted in that very first
talkie you ain't heard nothing yet the
nominations the best achievement in
sound are
the day of the dolphin Richard Portman
and Lawrence oh Jost
The Exorcist
Robert Knudsen and Chris Newman
the Paper Chase Donald Oh Mitchell and
Lawrence no joke
you
Paper Moon Richard Richard Portman and
less fresh Holtz
you
the sting Ronald K peers and Robert
Bertrand
the winner is Robert Newton and Chris
Newman for The Exorcist
speaking for Tadeo and all the fellow to
work with me but grands mock Bob glass
Weldon brown Pat Sullivan
I'd like to on behalf of all these
people thank the editors Warner Brothers
pictures and most of all bill freaking
man who made it all go together thank
you all very much thanks to Billy for
getting us through the movie to my crew
pet Sorachi and David Moshe Lac and to
all the people here and in New York who
made this possible thank
you